I feel like you guys pulled up like
right when y'all first signed with
capital so that was over a year ago
right yeah yeah I think y'all just
dropped the quago record yeah so so
welcome man A lot has happened since
then so including uh Drake cosign which
is [ __ ] huge all right shout out to
Jake you guys did the fire in the booth
freestyle and obviously uh Drake was a
fan did you guys already know before he
had like reposted your [ __ ] that he was
already kind of hip to what y'all were
doing
nothing about nothing you just wake up
one day and Drake post your freestyle
yeah wow that was crazy did he tap in at
all DM yeah
um any music coming out of it
yeah soon soon
so yeah I mean I feel like Drake lives
here a lot of the time he's here
obviously a lot and I feel like you know
he's always kind of I feel like you guys
are very like ahead of the curve on the
in the LA scene especially nationally
like especially on influence and [ __ ] I
feel like Draco was similar and he
tapped in with Draco pretty early you
know what I mean so
um Drake seems to be what was some of
the things that he had said to you guys
just like he was a fan did he listened
to any of the music or did you just see
the freestyle
I say you've been [ __ ] with the
movement for a minute yeah he was like
we gotta get something like
so did you guys send him something
you'll see man we're gonna see shout out
Drake though
so what you're saying is the next
project will be the Drake record no or
are you going to be on this new dragon
are you guys gonna be on the new Drake
21 Savage albums we need to be
you know I'm just fishing right now
yeah
um no that [ __ ] was dope to see man so
congrats to y'all y'all are definitely
killing it appreciate it